Ladies and gentlemen, our program is about to begin.
The AACR Annual Meeting is the focal point of the cancer research
community, where attendees gather to share the latest advances in
cancer science and medicine.
With the theme of Precision. Partnership.
Purpose.: Advancing Cancer Science to Save Lives Globally,
the AACR Annual Meeting highlights the work of the best minds in
cancer research from around the world.
Welcome to San Diego.
Good morning.
I'm Andrew Chan, and I'm a gastroenterologist and epidemiologist at
Massachusetts General Hospital.
It's my honor this morning to chair this special plenary
session on early-onset cancers.
These are my disclosures.
So the topic of early-onset cancers has really captured the
attention of the cancer research community, our patients, and their
families.
In addition, it has also captured the attention of the public.
This slide illustrates just a few of the headlines that have been
generated in one newspaper in the last year around the topic
of early-onset cancers.
Underlying these headlines is substantial population surveillance
data, which has demonstrated these rising trends of early-onset
cancer that are so alarming. And we're fortunate this morning to have as
our first speaker, Dr. Hyuna Sung of the American Cancer Society, who will
cover this topic.
In addition, when we think about early-onset cancer, we also need to think about
etiology. And the question is: why are we seeing such a rise in
early-onset cancer? This also obviously has captured the attention
of the public with an idea that understanding the why will help
us understand how to prevent these cancers in the future.
And so with that,
in my talk, I will focus on the emerging epidemiology around
colorectal cancer and how colorectal cancer is a
potential exemplar cancer for how we can study early-onset
cancer to lead to preventive interventions.
That will then be followed by a talk by Dr.
Ludmil Alexandrov, who will present some provocative data on the
potential role of the microbiome on early-onset cancers.
And then finally, this will be followed by Dr.
Pepper Shedden of Oregon Health & Sciences University, who will speak about
early-onset breast cancer.
So with that, it's my pleasure to present our first speaker,
who's Dr. Hyuna Sung. She's a senior principal
scientist at the American Cancer Society, and she's been a
leader in the field of population surveillance data, and she will cover these
really alarming trends across different cancer types. Welcome, Dr.
Sung.
Good morning, everyone.
It's truly an honor and privilege to speak here as a cancer
surveillance researcher. For me, this
invitation reflects the urgency we share in
understanding cancer trends
among young adults.
Before I begin,
I'd like to let you know that my talk will sound quite different
from the plenaries you've heard so far.
I will take us on a retrospective view, but by the end of the
talk,
I hope to leave you a prospective perspective as well.
I think we all agree on this.
Cancer incidence rates are rising among young adults across
multiple cancer types in many countries.
But beyond that, there is much less agreement on
what these trends signify and whether we should be
concerned.
Early-onset colorectal cancer is a clear exception, where the
evidence is strong and then the significance is
widely recognized.
But for other cancers, the increases are often
questioned, mainly for two reasons.
First,
even with a rapid increase, the absolute rates remain
low, raising concerns
that focusing on young onset cancer may divert the much
needed attention from cancers among older
adults. And second, the trends are largely
driven by the increased detection, not by a
true increase in the risk.
So today, rather than dismissing these trends or
oversimplifying them, I'd like to offer a
perspective that may help us better assess these
trends and start to disentangle the
complex drivers behind them.
Let me start with the burden. Every day, over
9,000 people under age 50 diagnosed with cancer
worldwide,
and over 3,000 die from the disease.
And yet, the burden of the disease among young adults
remains small,
about one in five cases and one in ten deaths.
And this obviously reflects the strong age gradient
in cancer risk.
And yes, the risk is very low in young people in general.
However,
cancer trends in young adults has long been a key
focus in cancer surveillance
researchBecause
they serve as early signals.
As they age,
they carry their risk forward to the future, and
by doing so, they shape and drive the future cancer
burden.
And here's an irony. To better assess cancer trends among young
adults, we may want to set aside age for the moment,
because age is a moving target.
Ask whether cancer rate is rising at age 45 in
1995 versus age 45 in
2025.
We are talking about entirely different generations who
grew up in different worlds
in terms of social norms, environment, technologies,
lifestyle, medical system, and so on.
And that's where birth cohort framework becomes powerful.
Instead of
following
people by age or calendar period, we follow
generations by birth year.
And that changes our question entirely.
Instead of asking whether cancer rates are rising among young adults,
we ask
whether today's young generation face a higher
cancer risk as they age, compared with their parent
generation.
A birth cohort framework allows us to capture cancer
risk across a lifetime, reflecting exposures
that
begin early in life and accumulate over time.
And this is particularly relevant
to young onset cancer or early onset cancers, where
latency may be shorter,
and then early life exposures may play a disproportionately
larger role.
And by setting aside age, we can more fairly compare the
risk across generations,
and we can even construct the whole trajectory of cancer risk
across generations, spanning decades, even a century.
And this is how we do it.
For each generation, we estimate cancer
rates across life course from the
youth to old age and distill this into a single
measure and compare them across generations.
But data are incomplete,
because we don't observe the full data for all
life course for each birth cohort.
So we need to rely on modeling.
The age-period cohort modeling fills in those gap
while accounting for the differences in age across
generations and also period influences.
By period influences, I refer to short-term and
abrupt changes in cancer incidence rates,
most often caused by
changes in detection and diagnostic practices.
In the following slides, I will present result that applied
this APC framework to the US National Cancer
Registry data,
along with selected international comparisons based on
CI5+ data compiled by International Agency
for Research on Cancer.
Let me start with the cancers
where incidence rates are higher among younger generations.
This slide shows 17 cancer types for which
people born in 1990 have higher rates compared
with those born in 1955.
The largest increase is seen for small intestinal cancer,
followed by thyroid, kidney, pancreatic cancers.
In the next tier, about twofold difference for breast,
female liver, uterine cancer, followed by
multiple GI cancers, including colorectal, and testicular
cancer at the end.
But this is just a partial view. Each cancer type
deserves a closer look, but I want to
focus a few cancer types to illustrate key birth cohort patterns.
Starting with colorectal cancer.
Cohort rate ratio is one of the most widely
used parameter that characterize birth cohort patterns.
It measures
relative difference in cancer risk across
birth years, using the midyear birth cohort as the
reference.
And here we see
now well-recognized U-shaped patterns for colorectal cancer.
The risk declines among those born in the first half of the
century and bottoms out among those born in the
'50s and then rises among those
born in second half of the century.
And this shape suggests that people born in the
'80s
may face about a 50% higher risk of developing
colorectal cancer as they age, compared with
those born in the '50s.
And on the right, this is a complementary view of how this birth
cohort trend translates to age-specific
trends for the last 20 years, measured as annual
percent change.
The blue box, the earlier decline among
older birth cohorts, drives the falling rates
of colorectal cancer among older adults.While the
progressive increase among younger recent
generations drives the rising early-onset
colorectal cancer among those under age
55.
The favorable trends of colorectal cancer among older
adults has been attributed to improvement in
lifestyle factors such as reduction in smoking, and
importantly, the widespread uptake of colorectal
cancer screening since the late '90s.
But the reasons for the rising risk among younger generation
remain less clear, with many in this room leading the effort
to uncover them.
Just published last week, this study reveals
a stark social disparity on early-onset colorectal
cancer mortality in the United States.
This graph shows
the past 30-year mortality trends among young men
by educational attainment.
While the mortality has increased
across both levels, it has been persistently
higher among young men with lower education, and
the gap between groups is widening over time.
A simple finding, but one with profound
implications,
not just for emerging risk factors, but also
for how our healthcare systems serve young adults
diagnosed with cancer.
Rising early-onset colorectal cancer incidence has now been reported
in at least 26 countries, and two patterns emerge.
In many high-income Western countries,
the increase is limited to young adults, while the
rates are falling or stabilizing among older adults.
In others, predominantly in Latin America and Asia,
the rates are increasing in both young and old adults.
We see similar patterns in mortality as well.
Here are two examples.
In Australia, the increase of mortality
is confined to young adults.
In Chile,
both age groups are being affected.
International comparisons of generational
cancer risk are limited, but they may
offer an important insights into underlying
drivers. In countries including Australia,
UK, Canada, and France, we see a similar
U-shaped pattern.
Consistently,
robust signals across countries,
despite differences in their environment and healthcare
systems, suggesting
progressively rising colorectal cancer incidence
among those born in '70s and '80s.
In second group of countries including Chile, Brazil,
Philippine, and South Africa, there is no earlier
decline,
only the steady rise of the risk across the successive
generations.
In this second group of countries,
rising risk of colorectal cancer among younger generation
creates a compounding challenge.
It's adding to the substantially large and still
growing mortality burden among older adults.
Let me turn to breast cancer, where the story becomes more nuanced.
Here we see clear divergence of birth cohort trend by
breast cancer subtype.
The red line on the left, the estrogen receptor-positive cancer.
The risk is relatively stable until mid-centuries,
but it rises among younger generation, peaking in
women born in 1990.
And this birth cohort trend
translates to faster increase of breast cancer
among younger women, although the rates are increasing in older
women as well.
In contrast, estrogen receptor-negative cancer,
the cohort rates declines across the successive
generations. This analysis does not include
any risk factor data, but this diverging pattern
suggests that breast cancer subtype-specific risk
factors might be shifting in opposite direction.
Endometrial cancer shows a similar pattern as
estrogen receptor-positive breast cancer.
The highest risk among the youngest birth cohort,
suggesting each successive generation of women
may be entering their adulthood with a higher
baseline risk compared with their mother's generation.
And this birth cohort trend, again, mirrored by
faster increase of endometrial cancer among younger women.
Now with thyroid cancer, similar but importantly
different.
Birth cohort trend increase in a linear
fashion without a clear change in the slope.
And thyroid cancer rise fairly uniformly across
all ages.
This pattern suggests the increase of thyroid cancer is
not tied to a particular generation.
Rather, it's a period effect, something that affects all age
groups
simultaneously.And
this pattern also highlights an important
limitation of APC modeling.
Even when the underlying driver is a period effect, the model can still
produce what appears to be a generational difference.
This can mislead us unless we pay close
attention to the shape of the curve, which we can test
statistically.
Here we see a similar pattern in pancreatic neuroendocrine
tumor.
Birth cohort trend increases in a linear fashion
and rates increase
fairly evenly across all age groups.
In contrast, pancreatic adenocarcinoma
is primarily rising among older adults.
Together, these patterns suggest that
the rise of pancreatic cancer overall reported among all
younger adults in the United States is likely driven
by increase in pancreatic
neuroendocrine tumors.
This graph shows instance trends of neuroendocrine
neoplasms
for last 25 years in the United States.
And there is a clear surge since 2013,
especially for localized disease.
And this timing closely aligns with the updates in the
WHO classification for digestive
system cancers, and also ICD coding changes
that expanded the definition of neuroendocrine tumors.
The increasing diagnosis of neuroendocrine tumor
is affecting trends in several GI cancers to varying
degrees. So moving forward, it's important to
separate these cancers in our analysis to better
capture more etiologically relevant subtype.
Stepping back,
we see a pattern.
Some cancers like colorectal, estrogen receptor-positive or
endometrial cancer, shows increases in
birth cohort trend in younger generations,
leading to faster or confined
increases of those cancers in young adults,
consistent with birth cohort effect.
Others, like thyroid cancer or pancreatic neuroendocrine tumor,
shows uniform rises across age groups pointing to
a period effect.
But in reality, this may not be a simple cohort
versus period stories.
Most cancers likely fall somewhere in between
with the relative contribution of each varying by cancer
types, reflecting the complex and heterogeneous
nature of cancer.
In other words, even for cancers with a strong birth cohort effect,
we cannot fully discount the influence of increasingly
sensitive diagnostics and expanding use of these
technologies over time.
On the flip side,
not all thyroid cancers or incidentally diagnosed cancers
are simply over-diagnosis. We know that some
early-stage cancers do carry metastatic
potential.
Let me turn to a more encouraging side of the story.
Some cancers show lower risk among younger generation,
including lung cancer, other smoking-related cancer,
cervical cancer, lymphomas, and melanoma.
And in the last few slides, I'd like to highlight lung and
cervical cancer.
The risk reduction in lung cancer in younger generation
is a striking example and reflects one of
the greatest public health success in the United States,
the reduction in smoking prevalence.
But the progress is never even
across countries or subpopulations with some groups
always falling behind.
This graph shows lung cancer incidence rates
as projected when each birth cohort
reaches age 60,
in a few countries by sex.
A clear pattern emerge.
The risk of lung cancer declines
in men
but increased or just plateaued in women.
As a result,
the sex gap in lung cancer risk narrows
among younger generation,
starting among baby boomers in the Netherlands,
Generation X in France,
millennials in South Korea, and
has not yet appeared, but probably younger in Belarus.
And these patterns send a signal about future
burden of
lung cancer.
Without stronger tobacco control for younger generations
of all genders, the progress will slow
and then burden will increasingly shift toward women.
The birth cohort perspective can also guide
prevention strategies, and here is one example.
Tobacco-free generation policy.
A shift from age-based sales ban to birth year
cutoff,
so those born after a certain year can
never legally purchase nicotine products.
Not an abrupt ban, but a gradual path
to
eliminate exposures altogether from
future generations.And finally, cervical
cancer. This graph shows cervical cancer incidence
rates as projected when each birth cohort reaches age 30.
And here we see a glimpse
how prevention efforts are reshaping the future.
After gradual declines, the risk has fallen
steeply, beginning with women born in
1988,
coinciding with one of the first birth years
eligible for HPV vaccination.
As a result,
women born in '90s now have
less than half the risk of those born in the '70s.
A remarkable difference between birth cohorts
born just 20 years apart.
But globally,
the progress is not even. In countries that implemented
HPV vaccination early, before 2010,
they are
seeing very similar benefits in younger generation,
but others with a delayed or limited rollout are
not.
This is yet another clear signal.
The global disparities in cervical cancer
may not only persist but also widen
unless we expand the access to HPV vaccination
and cervical cancer screening where they are needed the most.
All in all, these examples highlight the strength and
limitations of birth cohort analysis or APC modeling.
When it's grounded in high-quality population-based cancer registry
data, it enables to detect generational
shift in risk and identify birth cohorts at
higher risk, generate hypothesis on early life
exposure, and reveal the impact of prevention.
However,
it's fundamentally descriptive
and any inference is ecological at best.
Importantly, this modeling
cannot fully isolate cohort patterns free from
period influences. So we want to be cautious in using this
framework. Findings are highly context-specific,
varying by countries, sub-population, and cancer subtypes.
Like any modeling approach, it relies on assumptions and
carries uncertainties.
So I see birth cohort analysis not as a final answer,
but as a useful lens that help us see better what's
really changing.
Here are a few takeaways.
Again, cancer trends in young adults
serve as early signals for future burden of cancer.
Birth cohort framework is especially well-suited to
studying cancer trends in young adults and separating signal
from noise, as it captures early life exposures
and also
offer a fair comparison of the risk across generations.
Generational cancer risk can move both directions.
Rising risk among younger generation signal emerging
risk factors, while falling risk
demonstrates the power of prevention.
Rising incidence of cancers among young adults does
not reflect a single story.
Some cancers likely represent the true shift
in cancer risk among younger generations, but others
are more likely about changes in diagnostic intensity
and evolving disease classification of our time.
Finally, future gains and disparities are already taking
shapes in younger generations, from the widening social gap
in early onset
colorectal cancer mortality in the United States and also
global disparities in cervical cancer prevention.
So what should we do with these signals?
These are not just warnings, these are also opportunities.
Waiting until adulthood for prevention may be too late.
We want to start primary prevention earlier,
and we need a deeper understanding on early life
risk factors so the prevention can be more timely, effective, and
precise.
Research community has a responsibility
to distinguish and communicate better the underlying
drivers behind rising cancer incidence in young adults.
This attribution is critical to set priorities and
respond effectively. Finally,
cancer disparities found among younger generations
deserve urgent attention because disadvantages that
start early in life often persist a lifetime
and deepen future health disparities.
Before I close, I'd like to acknowledge the tremendous efforts
of population-based cancer registries worldwide.
Behind every trend shown today are decades of work
supported by government funding and international
agencies. Sustaining this commitment is vital
to tracking the progress we made against cancer and
identifying the remaining challenges, therefore,
better informing cancer prevention and control.
Finally, I'd like to acknowledge my colleagues and collaborators,
especially a few by name. Qinzhi Zhang, Kieran Kelly, our outstanding
associate scientists. Philip Rosenberg,
whose pioneering work in APC modeling has
deeply shapedMuch of this work. Freddie Bray,
for his leadership in global cancer surveillance.
And finally,
senior colleagues at the American Cancer Society, Ahmedin
Jamal and Rebecca Siegel,
for their invaluable insights and leadership in the field.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Dr. Sung, for that incredibly illuminating talk
and being able to really identify for us the importance of population
surveillance data, really understanding what's beneath the headlines for this
phenomenon of early-onset cancers.
And as Dr. Sung had nicely illustrated,
perhaps the most striking data with respect to early-onset cancer that's
emerged as an early signal has been in colorectal cancer.
So my task in this talk is to really dive more deeply into colorectal
cancer to help you understand where the state of the field is with respect to
epidemiology and understanding risk factors for early-onset colorectal
cancer, with an eye toward how we can move from those
correlations and association studies to causative
interpretation and ultimately to a landscape in which we can
lead to preventive interventions.
So I want to first start by laying out where we think we are
with colorectal cancer. And I think among early-onset cancers, we are perhaps the
farthest along with respect to understanding at least some risk factors for
early-onset disease.
This slide is just a summary of some of the risk factors that we've uncovered
through epidemiological studies in our group at Mass General Hospital, but
also Dr. Yin Cao's group at Washington University.
These risk factors include obesity, metabolic comorbid conditions,
diabetes, fatty liver, sedentary behavior,
drinking patterns, low vitamin D, sulfur
microbial diet or microbiome,
sugar-sweetened beverages, and poor diet quality.
Many of these risk factors cluster around metabolic dysfunction, which
I'll delve into in more detail in a moment.
I think what's been important about these studies is that they have given us clues
as to what might be changing in our environment that underlies this birth cohort
effect that Dr. Sung had mentioned.
And then I think, in particular, what's really important is how we can take these
association studies and try to develop them into a better understanding of what's
happening causally in the field, again, with an eye
toward prevention.
Many of these associations have been corroborated in other cohorts, but what's
really needed is additional studies to really identify what's causal
so that we can develop actionable preventive interventions among younger
generations.
So to this end, Dr. Cao and I were fortunate to pull
together this incredible team of investigators called Team
Prospect, which was supported by Cancer Grand Challenges two years ago to
tackle the question of why do we see a rising incidence of early-onset
cancer. And our focus is really on pathways, risk
factors, and molecules to really prevent early-onset colorectal tumors.
We've brought together a global team, and that's really essential because as Dr.
Sung illustrated, early-onset colorectal cancer has become a global
concern. And in addition, because it is such a vexing and
challenging problem, we need to bring together thought leaders across different
disciplines with diverse expertise to tackle this really difficult
problem.
So today, this presentation will be a summary of where we are with Team Prospect
to kind of, again, give you a sense of where we are on the landscape and to be able
to move forward again for the future as this team continues to progress in
its work.
So the framework by which Team Prospect really operates under is what we
call a causal pyramid,
where we basically have at the base of the pyramid life course
epidemiology cohorts to really examine risk factors across a life
course, which is really essential given that we know that cancers that
arise earlier in life must be due to risk factors that happen
earlier in life.
In addition, we layer onto those studies a convergence of
human and animal data to really get at a mechanistic understanding
of how these associations may actually contribute to cancer
risk.
And then finally, we hope to ascend that causal pyramid to the apex to
really get to the point of being able to develop interventions
that can actually reverse these risk factors and lead to
actionable solutions for patients and our families in younger
generations.
So going and trending across this causal pyramid from correlation to
causation to prevention is really the mission of Team
Prospect and where I think we need to go as a field when we tackle this early-onset
cancer problem.
So let's first start with correlation and association.
Where are we today with respect to understanding early-onset risk factors?
And again, that is really focused on using life course epidemiology
cohorts. But that's really been a limitation of the field, is that there are
very few life course epidemiology cohorts that are capable of answering
questions like early-onset cancer.
There are very few cohorts that have been developed with birth and early
childhood in mind, and certainly cohorts that have been formed are not
of sufficient size to really track people for a long enough period of time to
develop a sufficient number of incident cases to really study them with
a lot of rigor and reproducibility.
So it's required us to be creative in trying to understand this phenomenon
by pooling cohorts together but also leveraging existing cohorts so
we can start to get some answers to these really pressing
questions.So we really view early onset
colorectal cancer, as I mentioned, as a life course disease.
Because when we think about cancer risk in someone's 30s, 40s, and 50s, we
have to think about what they're exposed to, not only in that age group, but also
what they're exposed to earlier in life.
And this is a concept that we actually reviewed recently in a review
that was led by Mengxi Du, who is a junior faculty member in our group.
And our focus was really on metabolic dysfunction, which
arguably is perhaps the farthest
along the path and from getting to early life course
epidemiology to causality to prevention.
And so my focus today will be on metabolic dysfunction and obesity as sort of
a model for how we can think about life course studies to
identify risk factors for early onset cancer that can be potentially
intervenable.
So let's really try to leverage what we can from existing data.
And so much of what I'm going to present to you has been data that we've collected
through really important, large epidemiological cohort studies
that are based at Harvard, that have been funded for many years by the National
Cancer Institute and other entities that really illustrate the value of
population epidemiology data across decades of life.
These are the very well-characterized and well-known Nurses' Health Studies 1 and
2,
as well as the Health Professionals Follow-up Studies, which collectively have
enrolled over 250,000 individuals across several
decades.
And importantly, these really dedicated participants have given us very
detailed information on their lifestyle every two years, as well as
dietary information every four years, and have given us
permission to track them for the incidence of colorectal cancer over time.
In addition, we've tracked these participants for the incidence of colorectal
adenoma, the principal precursor lesion of colorectal cancer.
And so these studies are studies which have been very rich in data and have given
us some clues as to what leads we should follow with respect to risk factors
for early onset cancer.
I think one of the important components of these studies is that they really do
provide a snapshot of what's happening in the larger US
population. As Dr. Song nicely showed, there is this
U-shaped curve with colorectal cancer incidence and mortality, such that
generations born before 1955 show a
gradual decline in colorectal cancer incidence and mortality.
But that decline reverses after 1955, such that we're starting to see
these increasing rates of both cancer incidence and
mortality across different birth cohort generations.
So within the Nurses' Health Studies, in unpublished data led by Michael
Fuchs and Cindy Zhang in our group, they've nicely showed that the Nurses'
Health Studies do represent that same birth cohort, such that
colorectal cancer incidence and mortality has fallen by birth cohorts in
the Nurses' Health Studies, but then by 1950 have started to creep up as
well. And collectively, we can use this sort of information to look at the
compendium of data collected within these cohorts to understand what is sort of the
environmental risk factors that have changed across these participants over
time to provide us some insight into what might be underlying
this birth cohort effect nationally.
So let's first start with the easy questions, or not so easy questions, but at
least the basic questions. What are some of the exposures that we see in adulthood
that could be associated with early onset cancer?
So let's first look at, for example, risk factors when someone's
already an adult, in middle age or beyond.
So this was one of the early studies that Dr.
Cao led in using Nurses' Health Study 2 data, in which she
examined midlife adiposity and its association with early onset
cancer in the Nurses' Health Study 2.
And what she found was that BMI
at adulthood, when someone's already at middle age or beyond,
was associated with a higher risk of early onset cancer.
Specifically, individuals that were obese had a twofold higher incidence of early
onset cancer compared to those who were non-obese.
And this sort of obesity association in mid to late adulthood
represents obesity at a single time point, but also represents
a cumulative exposure to obesity over a life course.
How do we know that? Well, we do need to maybe look at some data that has been
collected during earlier adulthood.
There are very few cohorts that have enrolled people in this sort of younger age
range, but fortunately within the Nurses' Health Study 2, we also were
able to ask our participants about
their recall with respect to body mass index at an earlier phase in life.
So Dr. Cao nicely showed that when you look at BMI at age
18, there are also similar associations with early onset cancer.
And specifically, even BMI that's not considered to be obese,
but may be overweight or trending toward higher levels of body weight in the normal
range, are linked with about a 1.6-fold higher incidence of early onset
cancer compared to a referent category of normal weight.
So even body mass index at 18 is a reflection of a risk factor
of adiposity that could underlie the early onset, at least some of the
early onset cancer risk we're seeing in our participants.
But I think we want to also delve more deeply into other possibilities, and
certainly, we have to also look at the possibility that
exposure to overweight, obesity, or metabolic
dysregulation at earlier phases of life similarly are important to
consider when we think about cancer risk.
And that includes obesity and overweight in childhood to adolescence,
but even obesity and overweight in utero or in infancy,
to even think about the possibility that some of this effect of metabolic
dysregulation may be imprinted even before someone is born.
And this is a hypothesis that also is important to consider in the field and will
be explored more deeply by Dr. Alexandrov in a subsequent talk.
But I think we do have some early evidence that even in utero exposure to
obesity, adiposity, and an obesogenic environment may be linked to early
onset cancer. As I mentioned, there is a dearth of data from birth
cohorts, but we do have some clues.So within our Harvard
cohort studies, we were also fortunate to leverage data collected
among the members of our cohort's mothers.
So during different time points across follow-up, we
asked the participants in the cohort to give their mothers a questionnaire,
and the mothers were asked, "What were you exposed to when you were pregnant with
the participant?" and, "What were the participants
like as kids, and what were they exposed to?" And so that gives us some clues
as to potentially what's happening in early life among participants that are
being tracked very closely for cancer incidents over time.
And among these three cohorts, we had data from about 45,000 individuals.
So here are some of the domains that we collect in our mother's questionnaire.
We collect detailed information among the pregnancy factors
among which the mothers were exposed to when they were pregnant with the
participant. We also collected information about the participants when
they were infants.
So these are some early unpublished results, and this is work led by Fangyuan
Zhang, who is a student at the School of Public Health at Harvard, who's
supervised by Mingyang Song in our group.
And what they found was quite interesting, that among
the
participants in our study, if their mothers gained more
than 14 kilograms of weight during pregnancy, they had about a
two-fold higher incidence of those participants having colorectal cancer
subsequently during adulthood compared to the women
whose pregnancies in which they had the least amount of weight gain during
their pregnancy. So it does suggest that there's a potential
effect of an obesogenic environment in the maternal
setting, which may have a subsequent impact on cancer risk in the
future.
There are other exposure changes that have happened across birth cohorts within our
studies. You can see here looking at TV watching, for example, in children,
there's been a progressive increase in the amount of time people are
spending in front of the TV, which is a surrogate for
physical inactivity and for sedentary lifestyle.
In addition, looking at pregnancy factors during
pregnancy, we saw a gradual increase in alcohol intake across birth
cohorts. And also among children, we saw an increase in processed
meat intake over time. So there are these sort of birth cohort effects within our
cohorts that we want to explore further in additional studies.
So thinking about metabolic dysfunction obesity across the lifespan, we also want
to consider other factors. For example, are there environmental factors,
dietary factors, lifestyle factors, things that people are exposed to that may
contribute to cancer risk and that may also be mediated through metabolic
dysfunction?
So one such factor is the consumption of ultra-processed foods.
So ultra-processed food represents a type of food that
undergoes a large amount of industrial processing, which
includes the addition of a lot of preservatives, emulsifiers, oftentimes the
addition of salt and high fructose corn syrup.
And this type of food has been linked to a variety of metabolic
disorders. And it's become also something that's been
noticed to be upticking and trending across different age groups in the
US population. In particular, among US youth across different age groups,
there has been a substantial increase in ultra-processed food intake over the
years, both in age groups, but also in different races and
ethnicities.
Ultra-processed food has been linked to factors that have also been linked to
early-onset cancer. So this is work led by Dr.
Du, and she found using a cohort called GUTS.
This is a cohort of offspring of Nurses' Health Study Two
participants that have been followed in childhood when they were between the
ages of seven and 17. And what she showed in this study was
that exposure to an even just 10% increase in
ultra-processed food intake can result in substantial and
significant increases in body mass index in children over different time
periods. So there is a link, again, with ultra-processed food
intake and metabolic disturbances in children, which could set
them up for cancer risk in the future.
Ultra-processed foods also been linked with a variety of metabolic conditions in
adults, as shown in this meta-analysis, and that includes issues
around metabolic health that have been well-characterized in other studies,
including abdominal obesity, overweight, and type 2 diabetes.
So to look at the association potentially of ultra-processed food with early-onset
cancer, we asked this question within our Nurses Health Study Two cohort and
specifically asked the question: Does ultra-processed food associate with a
higher incidence of developing these precancerous polyps that we know lead to
early-onset cancers or early-onset adenomas?
And this is work that was led by Chun Wang in our group that was recently published
that showed that the women who were consuming the highest quintile of
ultra-processed food, as classified by what we call the NOVA
classification, a commonly used scheme to classify ultra-processed food, they had
about a 1.5-fold higher incidence of developing adenoma
compared to those in the lowest quintile.
So those were some early clues, again, as to what might be happening with respect
to risk factor changes in different birth cohorts.
Now we want to also understand not only what are associations but what are
causal. And ideally, to be able to ascend the causal pyramid, we would
love to have trial data, to have experimental data in humans, to be able
to say these cancer risk factors linked to cancer when we actually give
them to people or when we reverse those cancer risk factors in clinical trials.
But those trials are incredibly difficult to do, and for anyone who does prevention
research, really the difficulty in doing prevention trials is the
length of time you need to follow individuals and the size of these cohorts.
So we need to rely on another source of evidence.
And so within our causal pyramid, we really wanted to use and
utilize data from human and animal models to give us
experimental data around mechanism that can allow us to infer causality.
And so here are a couple of examples of thatSome of
the key biological pathways that we think link metabolic disturbance
with early onset cancer are outlined here, and again, summarized in our
review that was recently published.
This sort of axis of obesity and type 2 diabetes is linked to multiple
risk factors and mechanisms that have been linked to early onset and late onset
cancer. In particular, we've wanted to focus on insulin
resistance because that seems to be a very consistent association across different
epidemiological studies. So how do we use human
biospecimens and translational data to really get at causality with
respect to insulin resistance?
So to do that, what we did was we took an approach where in our epidemiological
cohorts, we have archived biospecimens.
And in these archived biospecimens, we've also measured levels of
C-peptide, which is a circulating biomarker of
hyperinsulinemia. Within a sub-cohort of individuals in the
Nurses' Health Study Too, we use measures of circulating
C-peptide to indicate hyperinsulinemia and develop what we
call an empirical lifestyle index for hyperinsulinemia, meaning what are
the lifestyle and dietary factors that would predict who would have the highest
levels of circulating insulin?
And in this study, what Dr. Wang did was she
examined this lifestyle index in relationship to early onset adenoma
and found that the women in the study that had the highest
predicted levels of circulating insulin had about a 1.3-fold higher
incidence of early onset adenoma compared to those in the lowest quintile.
So giving us some mechanistic associations that will allow us to
connect ultra-processed food, for example, to early onset
adenoma. And then as Dr. Sung had referenced, we also need
to think more and more about our studies epidemiologically as needing to rely on
exposures by birth cohort as opposed to arbitrary age
cutoffs. And so we've also looked at these associations by birth cohort,
and when we actually divide the cohort by birth cohort, we see that the individuals
that were born in the later birth cohorts that really reflect this rising
incidence of colorectal cancer, they were the group that had the
higher incidence of adenoma when they were in the highest
quintile of predicted hyperinsulinemia, whereas the earlier
birth cohorts, that sort of hyperinsulinemia association really didn't seem to
be as strong. So again, giving us some mechanistic clues as to what
might be causal.
There's also additional evidence that we can think about gut microbial
dysbiosis as a convergent pathway by which these lifestyle factors may
lead to early onset cancer as well as late onset cancer.
And this will be delved into in a lot more detail in Dr. Alexandrov's talk.
But just to give you some sense of potentially the association with metabolic
disorders, I want to highlight this recent meta-analysis that was published
last year by Nicola Segata's group, led by Gianmarco
Pecino, a postdoctoral fellow and member of our PROSPECT team, where
he showed that there are many different species that are
correlated and anti-correlated with colorectal cancer.
And I think what's important about this is that these potential
species linked to colorectal cancer risk are also quite
correlated with cardiometabolic risk.
So if you see here on this
graph, looking across different stages of colorectal cancer, there's a
remarkable level of concordance, about a 20 to 30%
concordance in the species that would predict cardiometabolic risk with
colorectal cancer risk. So really suggesting that there is strong evidence
supporting cardiometabolic changes as being a risk factor for early onset
cancer.
And then I want to turn finally to epigenetic regulation, because I think we're
thinking more about the idea that not only are people exposed to different things
across a life course, but also early life exposures may not need to be
sustained across a life course to lead to future cancer risk.
So what is the epigenome? The epigenome is an information processing
hub where we consider environmental factors, for example, obesity,
ultra-processed food, microbiome, as interacting with a cell,
which subsequently leads to downstream expression of transcription
factors that then preferentially bind to areas of chromatin on
the genome that tends to regulate or upregulate
expression of certain gene programs.
So that epigenetic regulation of what's expressed in the cell is really
critical for ultimately what's happening physiologically.
So again, looking again at human animal convergent data,
Jason Buenrostro's lab in our team PROSPECT in work led by Surya
Nagaraja, a postdoctoral fellow, looked at an animal model of inflammation
to assess, can inflammation be potentially an epigenetic
mark on colorectal tissue that then leads and predisposes
people to future cancer susceptibility?
So in a mouse model in which they induce acute colitis with DSS,
allow the mice to recover to a state of chronic colitis, and
eventually to a state of complete recovery, they showed that you can have
morphologically
descriptive changes in which acute colitis does lead to epithelial changes that
may become chronic, but once the colitis recovers, that
mucosa or that colorectal epithelium begins to look
morphologically normal. But taking tissue samples collected at these
different time points, they're able to then look at both epigenetic
regulation through single-cell ATAC-seq and also gene
expression through single-cell RNA-seq through a novel method known as
SHARE-seq.
And with SHARE-seq data, they really showed that there is latent memory that's
really encoded in chromatin. Specifically, in their model, what
they showed was that when you measure chromatin accessibility, here measured
by change in AP1 motif accessibility, you can see that
in acute colitis, as it becomes chronic, there is a gradual
increase in chromatin accessibility as measured by AP1,
and that actually continues to be sustained even after that colitis
has recovered.
In contrast, when you look at transcription factor protein expression,
as measured, for example, by the Fos transcription factor, you can see here in the
acute setting, Fos protein expression increases and then
does also increase with chronic colitis, but then when the colitis recovers,
transcription factor expression goes back to normal.When you
look at gene expression also the same pattern.
You can see in the control setting and acute setting, there's a gradual
increase in expression of certain pathways related to wound repair and
inflammation. Those pathways may be back to normal and
downregulated in the recovery state.
But what's really changed and persisted is the idea that chromatin accessibility
remains high even though
morphologically the tissue is also healed, and
also by protein expression and gene expression, the tissue looks normal.
So that chromatin accessibility represents a potential molecular scar that
could predispose to cancer in the future.
And that's indeed what they show in a different mouse model.
So looking at a mouse model of APC deletion, what they
showed was that in mice that had no prior history of colitis or
inflammation, when you basically delete APC, you do
form adenomas. But in a mouse that had a history of chronic colitis,
despite that colitis having resolved itself, that APC
deletion does result in greater tumor burden.
So this creates this model that we hope to pursue in more detail in Team
Prospect, looking at a variety of lifestyle factors such as obesity,
ultra-processed food microbiome, in which it can plausibly lead
to an acute insult, maybe early in life, maybe
somewhere in childhood or mid-adulthood, in which there is
inflammation and damage that you can see in the tissue.
And it leads to also a change in chromatin accessibility.
And although the tissue may start to heal over time, as shown here,
that chromatin accessibility marker continues to be there in the
tissue. And when that tissue is further exposed in the future to oncogenic
mutations,
that can lead to an augmented secondary response with tumorigenesis.
So I think epigenetic memory can be a convergent pathway by which
multiple lifestyle factors can predispose individuals to future
cancer risk.
So finally, I want to turn to the last
part of the presentation, which is around the top of the pyramid, the
apex, really that prevention setting.
Because ultimately this early onset situation is something that we want to get to
the bottom of because we want to have some actionable solutions in the near term
for prevention. And that's really the apex of the pyramid and where
the
field needs to go to really make progress in this really difficult
problem.
So how do we advance causality to prevention?
And I won't have time to go into detail with any of these specific
interventions, but I want to really highlight the fact that
among these different pathways, we know that there are central nodes.
We know inflammation is a central node.
Obesity is a node, dysbiosis is a node.
They all represent opportunities for us to do something about this problem.
For inflammation, for example, we know there are anti-inflammatory agents like
aspirin, and there's a very strong evidence base supporting the fact that aspirin
reduces colorectal cancer risk. And certainly, that represents a very viable option
in a young population for whom risk factors are
there for inflammation and chronic development of
polyps and cancer.
But they're also a population for which
potential side effects of aspirin are much lower.
In addition, we know that they're highly effective agents against obesity and
type 2 diabetes that have also been discussed widely in this meeting and in other
meetings. And so GLP-1 receptor agonists may represent a potential
preventive intervention.
And then finally, we know there are ways potentially to modulate the gut
microbiome through dietary interventions, fiber supplementation, et cetera.
So these are all potential options for prevention.
So one of these options is something we're pursuing within Team Prospect,
looking at highly effective obesity agents.
So in a cohort of adults between the ages of 40 to 49 with a history of
adenoma that we see at Mass General Hospital,
we are currently enrolling patients in a trial, a single-arm trial, where we're
treating them with tirzepatide,
which is a GLP-1 GIP agonist. And at baseline, we're doing a
flexible sigmoidoscopy, collecting tissue samples, as well as a variety of
biosamples like blood, urine, and stool.
Following them over time serially with a checkout visit at
six months,
which also includes a flexible sigmoidoscopy in which we're using tissue biopsies,
et cetera. And this will give us some correlative biomarkers to understand, are
there epigenetic markers that change with reversal of
obesity overweight? Are there also cancer-specific
biomarkers that we can look at? And so this study is being led at MGH
by David Drew and myself, and we're hopeful that we're going to have some results
to report out next year.
Finally, I do want to note that there's the question about do we need to even
intervene earlier? And as Dr. Alexandrov will talk about, if some of these
lifestyle factors and some of these metabolic risk factors or microbiome factors
really do happen really early in life, how do we then intervene?
Because it's very difficult to imagine a scenario where we would repurpose
pharmacological agents for infants or for pregnant mothers.
So that's where we have to really think about new ways or new modalities of
implementation science, and policy changes, where maybe we can
try to alter some of these obesogenic exposures
through policy changes, where we can maybe alter our food environment to eliminate
some of these things from a national perspective and eliminate some of the
disparities that we see in early-onset cancer risk, which Dr.
Sung also nicely mentioned.
So in summary, I hope we've been able to show you how early-onset colorectal
cancer is an area in which we've made some progress.
We're understanding more about it, and we're starting to develop some opportunities
for prevention, which I think is so critically needed in the field.
It also requires us to have a life course framework.
We need to also be able to develop mechanistic models using both mice
and also human samples to really advance correlation to causality, because clinical
trial data is going to be very difficult to come by.
And ultimately, causality can be advanced to prevention
through proof-of-principle human trials.So I want to
acknowledge the folks in my group at MGH who've
led a lot of the data that I presented here today.
Certainly, our co-investigators on Team Prospect, just a remarkably
dedicated team of investigators, in particular Ian Cowell, my co-lead
of this team, as well as our really dedicated patient advocates.
And I can't emphasize enough how our patient advocates have been so
vital to this program. They've been with us every step of the way in both
informing the design of our research, but also inspiring us to really
address this challenging problem.
The participants of all of our studies, we want to acknowledge our funders, and
also just want to mention that a lot of these topics and a lot of these issues
around prevention and how we prevent cancers are areas that we hope to
cover at a cancer prevention research conference that we're having
in June, that I have the privilege of co-chairing.
So if you're interested in attending that conference, the QR code is there.
So with that, I thank you for your attention.
And now I do want to take the opportunity to introduce
our next speaker. We're very happy to present Dr.
Ludmil Alexandrov from University of California,
San Diego. He's a professor
of molecular medicine, and he will discuss early life mutagenesis and
the rise of early onset cancer. Thank you for your attention.
Good morning, everyone. I'm delighted to be here and to tell you more
about our work on early onset colorectal cancer, and
specifically on our work on how early life
mutagenesis can be contributing to early onset colorectal cancer.
Now, most talks end with a summary.
My talk is going to actually end with a hypothesis, and I really hope that this
hypothesis will excite at least some in the audience.
Oh, and of course, these are my disclosures.
Please keep them in mind while I'm presenting.
So I'm going to start with an overview of somatic mutations, mutational
signatures, and human cancer. We have known for
quite a while that somatic mutations accumulate daily.
They accumulate in every single cell of the body, and they can accumulate
from lifestyle choices, they can accumulate from failure of
cellular mechanisms, and also they can accumulate just because the cell exists,
the cell divides, the cell generates energy.
So somatic mutations and their accumulation are just part of daily life.
Now, we have known also for maybe four or five decades that cancer
risk is strongly affected by mutagenesis.
The more mutations one accumulates, the higher the risk for developing
cancer. And this is perhaps best exemplified by tobacco smoking, which
mutates multiple organs of the human body, perhaps most notably the
lung. And again, if we look at lung squamous cell carcinoma,
one type of lung cancer, only one patient with this cancer
type will report being a never smoker, while the remaining 104
patients will report being smokers.
So you have something that increases the mutational burden, generates many
mutations, and substantially affects cancer risk.
So perhaps 10 or 15 years ago, the question came,
if we look at cancer genomes, if we look at the next-generation
sequencing data from cancer genomes, can we say what is
generating these mutations? Can we figure out the mutational processes causing
mutations and the mutational causes of cancer using
these mutational processes? And essentially, this became known as mutational
signature analysis, a simple machine learning approach that you apply to
next-generation sequencing data.
And I just want to give you some examples, some poster child examples.
So when we think about skin cancer, we usually think about
ultraviolet light exposure, because majority of skin cancers are caused
by UV light exposure.
And indeed, UV light exposure has a very characteristic pattern of mutations.
You can see it here, predominantly C to T mutations in a very
specific context. That context is dipymidines, very well
matching the biophysical properties of UV light.
So if we look at skin, healthy skin, we are going to see
this UV light exposure
generating many mutations across these healthy skin
genomes. But also, if we look at the genomes of melanomas,
we're going to see very high levels of this mutational signature.
Now, in lung cancer, again, most of the time, we associate lung
cancer with tobacco smoking, and indeed, about 80% of all types
of lung cancer are caused by tobacco smoking.
And when we look at the genomes of these lung cancer patients, we're going to see
again another characteristic pattern of mutation, also Signature
4, generating predominantly blue mutations and some gray mutations
here, and leaving its mutagenic pattern just because a
person smokes. Now again, the mutational
signatures not only allow us to
find an exposure, but they allow us to evaluate how an
exposure is going to mutate the normal tissue.
So if we have a person who is smoking a pack of cigarettes per day for a
year, on average, every single cell of their lung tissues is going to
accumulate about 150 mutations, their larynx 97
mutations, and you can see the numbers for the other parts of their
body. And this mutational increase very nicely tracks with the risk
that tobacco smoking confers for developing cancer in these different
organs. Now, over the last 10 or 15 years,
there has been many studies on identifying the repertoire of mutational
signatures, and we and others have mapped over 100 mutational
signatures across the spectrum of human cancers.
You have processes happening within the cells.
You have processes that are happening due to treatment,
whether chemotherapy or other treatment.
And we also have processes that are due to environmental exposures or
exogenous mutagens. So there is quite a plethora of different
exposures, and from the over 100 mutational signatures that we have
identified, more than half we do not know what's their
cause.Now, one signature that's specifically important for this
talk is the signature of colibactin.
And colibactin, if you're not familiar with that, it's a
genotoxin that's being produced by certain bacteria, and more
specifically, by certain types of E.
coli and other bacteria that carry the pks locus.
And from an experimental perspective, this mutational signature was
first
described by Hans Clevers in a very elegant work
where Hans and his team
grew intestinal organoids, some with the pks positive
bacteria, and some without the pks positive bacteria.
And then they clonally expanded them, they sequenced them, and they found this very
nice mutational signature, which they called the signature of pks
positivity. And then at the same time, many studies of human
cancers and normal tissues were analyzing cancer genomes
or normal colorectal tissues, and they found Signature 88.
And again, you can see that the patterns of this Signature 88 matches almost
perfectly the pattern of the experimental pks signature.
And indeed, Signature 88 became the mutational signature of colibactin,
and in addition to that, there is an additional insertion and deletion
signature. So mutational signatures allow us to
understand the processes that cause mutations and about maybe now
10 years ago, the field of genomic epidemiology
started utilizing them to understand the causes of
cancer.
And we were very lucky in 2017 to be funded by
Cancer Research UK as part of the Mutographs Grand Challenge to
try and understand why different countries around the world have
different risks for developing cancer. And the idea was simple.
We're going to go around the world, we're going to sequence tumors, and we're going
to see whether they have different mutational signatures and whether we can
explain the cancer risk based on mutational
signatures. And one of those cancer types was colorectal
cancer. And again, the previous two talks very nicely
emphasized that colorectal cancer has been increasing in young adults
and has been decreasing in older generations, but just to keep in mind, there
is also differences of colorectal cancer risk around the world,
with some countries having substantially higher risk for developing colorectal
cancer than others. And when we were conducting our study, our original
objective was to investigate that, to understand why certain countries
have a high risk for colorectal cancer and certain countries have a lower risk for
colorectal cancer. At the same time, the emergence of early
onset colorectal cancer was becoming more and more prominent or more than a
twofold increase, as we heard before.
It was mapped as a global phenomenon with
over 27 countries reporting the increase of early onset colorectal
cancers. And again, there were not really any known
risk factors that were described except perhaps the ones that Andy was
mentioning just a moment ago.
And it is becoming the leading cause of death among young
adults. And again, as it was emphasized in some of the previous talks, this was
very highly featured in the general media with many different
headlines
talking about early onset cases and specifically early onset colorectal
cancer. Now, I should say that when we started our study,
our focus was actually to understand geographic differences.
We wanted to understand why some countries have more cancers than others.
And indeed, we collected about 1,000 colorectal cancers, all of
them treatment-naïve, and we collected them from 11 countries with
different risks for cancer. And you can see there's countries with high risk
for cancer, such as Japan, which has ASR, or a
standardized risk over 35, and there are countries with low risk for
developing cancer, such as Iran and Thailand.
And for each of those tumors, we did whole genome sequencing of the tumor and
normal, and then we derived somatic mutations.
Now, just because early onset cases were increasing so much, we
were able to capture over 130 early onset colorectal
cancers as part of that cohort. And indeed, we were able to capture early
onset cases both in the proximal tumor, in the proximal colon,
distant colon, and in the rectum, and with different percentages.
But again, quite the representative view of early onset cases and late
onset cases.
Now,
there is many ways to show you colorectal cancer, but I wanted to do it in probably
the most genomics way one can do, and that's by looking at
mutations.
And what you can see here on this y-axis is the single point mutations or the
single base substitutions, and this is log scale, so you have 10,000,
100,000, a million mutations. On this x-axis, you can
see what percentage of the genome is altered, so how genomically unstable
is colorectal cancer. And here you can see the insertions and deletions, how
many small base pairs are deleted in colorectal cancer.
And the first type of colorectal cancer, molecular subtype of colorectal cancer, is
the microsatellite stable tumors.
These are tumors that there is no defects in any known DNA repair
mechanisms, and they have on average about maybe 10,000
mutations, and they have about 1,000 to 2,000
insertions and deletions. Now, as you can see, their genomes could be stable
or very unstable. They're from the full spectrum.
And about 800 of the 1,000 samples were microsatellite
stable. The second category is microsatellite unstable
tumors, and again, these are about 150 of the
1,000 tumors. And now you see tumors that have substantially more
mutations, an order of magnitude more, and about two orders of
magnitude more insertions and deletions.
So the failure of mismatch repair in these tumors have generated a very different
molecular profile.
One can obviously validate this clinically with digital droplet PCR or
immunohistochemistry, and all the ones here have been validated.
And there is also other ones such as the polymerase epsilon and polymerase delta.
Now, these tumors have millions of mutations,
and they have very stable genomes.
And there are even more rare subtypes.
You have the MUTYH, the NTH1, the OGG1.
We had seven patients with BRCA2 mutations.
So again, out of 1,000 patients, less than 1%
having different types of DNA repair defects and exhibiting
different molecular phenotypes.One
thing that we were surprised to see is
signatures of chemotherapy. About two samples that
we examined had chemotherapy signatures, and again, our cohort was
supposed to be a chemotherapy-naive cohort.
We were not supposed to have any treatment.
And again, when we went and looked at the data, it turned out that these people had
prior cancers. One of them had a prior cancer in childhood.
That person was treated, and the treatment left this
mutational imprint,
and we can detect it later within their secondary tumor, which was colorectal
cancer. So the fact that you have an exposure earlier in life, you can
keep seeing these mutations later in life.
Now, as you can imagine, some of these categories are very small.
You have just a few samples in them.
So we reported them, and essentially we reported their rates,
and we left them aside because they have very different molecular profiles.
We did a deep dive on the microsatellite unstable tumors.
Again, they have about an order of magnitude more mutations.
So
failure of DNA repair really generates many mutations,
and we weren't able to find anything statistically significant.
So again, we have reported that, but we have put them aside.
And our main results and the main focus has been on the microsatellite stable
tumors, because these are the tumors where we know there is no failure of DNA
repair and where we can really evaluate different
environmental exposures.
Now,
there we did the mutational signature analysis, and we found a large
number of different signatures. And I'm not going to tell you all
the details. I'm just going to tell you that we found the usual suspects, the
clock-like signatures that are due to aging, the APOBEC signatures
due to deaminases, reactive oxygen species,
colibactin, which is going to become important in just a moment, and
then many signatures that have unknown etiologies, many
signatures that we do not know what is causing
them.
And again, this is just the single point mutations.
We did mutational signature analysis across all different types
of somatic mutations. So the first question that we wanted to
answer is, are there differences between countries?
This is the original question we started with, and we wanted to understand whether
we can observe any differences. And again, one needs to do this
carefully. We did one versus all comparison while adjusting by age,
sex, tumor subtype, and purity, and we can see clear differences.
So when one compares the Russian Federation to all other countries, you can see
enrichment of APOBEC signatures and novel signatures of unknown
etiology. Argentina, we see three novel
signatures or three signatures of unknown etiologies being enriched there.
In Brazil, one signature being enriched.
In Colombia, three signatures being enriched and one being
depleted, again, all of them of unknown etiologies.
And in Thailand, one signature that's being depleted.
And you can see how this looks on a map.
You can see Signature F, which we do not know what causes it, and you see that
it's very highly prevalent in Colombia.
We find it all over the world, but the prevalence is highest
in Colombia in this specific case.
And again, you can see here SBS89 and the signatures that
usually strongly correlate with it, the IDG and BBS8, very
common in Argentina. Again, we see it in the rest of the world, but
we do not know what its etiology is.
So we were seeing these many signatures.
We were discovering these signatures that may even explain the difference in cancer
risk, but we could not know their causality.
We didn't know their underlying mechanisms.
And as you can imagine, this could be a deeply frustrating exercise because you
really want to understand what causes the signatures if you want to prevent cancer.
And I'm very delighted to say that starting in 10 days,
we have been funded for a cancer grant challenge specifically for that, to be able
to investigate the mechanisms of these mutational signatures and being
able to understand what underlies their mechanisms.
And we're hoping to be able to report more interesting details
versus we have signatures of unknown etiology.
Rather, we want to be able to report this is a signature, this is what causes these
signatures, and ideally, this is the way we can prevent this signature.
Now, this was a comparison between countries.
What about the early onset cases? And there we had probably the most interesting
result in our analysis. When we separated our case
based on the age of people, we can see a very high
enrichment for at least three mutational signatures,
SBS88 and ID18, both of them due to
colibactin. One is the indel signature, the other one is a substitution signature,
and SBS89, which is a signature of unknown etiology.
And to give you an idea, the colibactin mutational signature is found in about
50% of people under the age of 40 and about 16% to
17% of people over the age of 70. So we're talking
about a threefold difference between these different age groups.
So that was quite the striking result.
And again, we knew the mechanism of this signature, which meant we can look in more
details in this signature. And the first question we ask is,
well, if this is due to pks positive bacteria, do we see
colonization of that bacteria? And again, you can see a
sample here. This is one patient that has the pks positive
signature. And also we can look at the sequencing data, and we can see that there
is pks colonization. And there is another patient here.
Again, it will have the
colibactin mutational signatures, but it has absolutely no pks
reads. And you can do the same analysis across the complete cohort, and what
we saw is that there was no associations of us seeing
colonization and us seeing the presence of a
mutational signature. And that was true across the complete cohort, and that was
also true across all different age groups.
And again, that could make sense. You do not need to have colonization in this
very moment. You could have had a past exposure to this genotoxic
bacteria that generates the mutations.
And then the question came, when was that exposure?
Can we go back in time? When were these people exposed to this
specific colibactin signature?So the first thing we did is to time it
from a cancer evolution perspective.
I'm not going to go to the way the cancer evolution
timing and modeling works, but the results were very, very
conclusive. The colibactin signatures were some of the earliest
processes in cancer evolution that were happening very
early as the cancer was starting to develop.
Now, that doesn't tell us the age of the person when that tumor
develops, but it tells us it's one of the earliest processes in cancer.
But we really wanted to get to that question, at what age do these people get
exposed? And again, to do that, one needs to do a bit of
fancy molecular archeology. And the way one does that
is to take normal colorectal crypts from a cancer patient.
Here you see 15 of them. Each one of those colorectal crypts is whole
genome sequenced, and then they're put on a phylogenetic tree.
And again, based on that phylogenetic tree, one can time when this signature
occur. And this is very similar to how one times species
evolutions or how one times bacteria or viruses emergence
by using these phylogenetic trees and some markers of time.
And again, you can see here these are two colorectal crypts that have been
sequenced. They have a shared trunk, and that means they had
a shared ancestor. And that shared ancestor, as you can see,
the pink color here is the colibactin mutational signature, and that means
all the colibactin exposure happened in the shared ancestor.
And because we do not see any of the pink in the leaves, that
means this is something that happened in the ancestor, but it
didn't happen subsequently after the ancestor became these two
different colorectal crypts. So it's something that happens once or
it happens at one time point and then stops.
Now I'm showing you one phylogenetic tree. There is over 100 of those.
In almost every single case, you see this consistent result, something that
happens
at a single time point. Now, we can time that.
You can see there you have the clock-like mutational signatures.
We know how these signatures tick.
We can use their timing to say at what age does this happen.
And when we do this timing, you can say this is happening within the first five
years of life. So we're talking about an exposure that happens
in early childhood.
Excuse me.
Now, the question, okay, so we have an exposure.
That exposure happens early in life, early in tumor evolution, but does it
generate any driver mutations? Is it actually causative?
So then we looked at the APC driver, some of the first hit in the colorectal cancer
evolution, and we saw that in the colibactin cases, a substantial
proportion, more than 25%, were regenerated by the
colibactin mutational signature.
So not only did we have the
colibactin generating
mutational process, but generating some of the early driver mutations or some of
the first driver mutations in colorectal cancer evolution.
Now, what I'm going to do now, I'm going to summarize the talk, and I'm going to
tell you our hypothesis of what we think is causing some of the early onset
cases. So as part of the Mutographs Cancer Grand Challenge, we
profiled 1,000 colorectal cancers from 11 countries,
including 102 early onset cases. Again, you see all the
molecular subtypes that you expect for colorectal cancer.
There are over 47 different mutational signatures, most of them with
unknown etiologies. We are really looking forward to figuring out what causes these
signatures and whether we can explain cancer risk with them.
Multiple signatures are associated and highly enriched with early onset cases.
The one with colibactin
indicates that there has been a past colonization of pks+ positive
bacteria. And when you time that, you see it's happening early in the tumor
evolution, and it's happening very early in life.
But you don't only have a mutagenic exposure, you have a mutagenic exposure that's
generating some of the first driver mutations in colorectal cancer.
So based on that, we can construct a hypothesis
and our hypothesis is that early life exposure to the microbiome
carcinogens is actually causing at least some of the increase in early onset
cases. And it goes like this, you have a child, that child is
young, and it has colonization of this colibactin or other
mutagen producing bacteria. That
mutagenic bacteria generates many, many mutation in the colon tissue,
potentially some of the early drivers, and now you have a young child with many
mutations who is on the fast track for developing
cancer. Now,
this hypothesis has some support, and that support
comes specifically from looking at colorectal crypts in children.
All of the previous data I showed you, we were trying to time when the mutations
are happening. In this specific case, these are colon crypts from children that
have been whole genome sequenced.
And these are children from Europe, from the UK,
and there is about 80 of them. In 40% of these children, we
see colibactin exposure, and again, in majority of those children,
we see this colibactin exposure happening before the age of five.
But there is several different cases. You can see this child here.
This child has a small number of colibactin mutations, and it had
probably a very small exposure. And we wouldn't think that this specific
child would have high risk for developing cancer.
It has the clock-like signatures, but it doesn't have specifically a large number
of mutations. But there's other cases like this child here,
which I believe is either two or three years old, which has many, many thousands of
colibactin mutations being imprinted in colorectal epithelium.
And it has the mutational burden of some in their late 50s.
And if you have that many mutations at age two, well,
then our hypothesis would be that
these type of individuals will potentially have a higher risk for developing early
onset colorectal cancer later in life.
Now, I just want to try to say what we know for this hypothesis at the
moment. We know that the colibactin signatures are detected in about 40% of
normal colorectal crypts in children in the UK.
We suspect this will be very similar in the US and the rest of
Western Europe. We know that the colibactin signatures are very highly, three to
four times-fold enrich in early onset cases
versus late onset cases, and we do know for certainty that this
exposure happens before the age of five.
In fact, we think maybe it happens between the first nine to 18
months of life. So we're talking about a very, very early exposure.
The hypothesis, again, just to restate it here, is the colibactin is
generating these mutations, potentially generating these early driver mutations,
and again, putting you on a fast track for developing cancer because you have the
first hit, and then you can over age develop the second hit and the additional
clonal expansion. But you get cancer at age 20, 30,
40 instead of age 60, 70.
This is a hypothesis, and there is a lot of things that we need to prove to be able
to make sure that we understand it.
First,
we need to make sure that these signatures have been actually increasing with
the rates of early onset cancer. We don't know whether the
colibactin signatures have been increasing at the moment with the way early onset
cases have been increasing. So it is possible that this is an
exposure that has always existed, and that's the first time we capture it, or it's
possible that something has increased in recent years.
The second thing we need to do is we need to do a proper case control studies.
At the moment, we're comparing early onset cases to late onset cases.
What one needs to do and what we are planning to do is to compare
the normal colorectal tissues of early onset colorectal cancer carriers to age,
sex matched individuals that do not have early onset colorectal
cancer. And if this is causative, you're going to expect more mutations in the
cases versus the control. And the last and not least thing is trying
to think about intervention. How can we remove this exposure?
How we can modulate it, especially with something happening in early life?
And there is a number of ideas there, from symbiotic to different
types of intervention to make sure that children are not being
exposed to this mutagenic exposure.
Now, I should say that we have
summarized this hypothesis in a very nice cancer discovery piece.
It's one and a half pages. So if you're interested and if you
find that exciting, please, there is the QR code.
We have summarized what we know at the moment.
We have summarized ways to test this specific hypothesis and what we
didn't mean for the hypothesis to be true or to be false.
And again,
special thanks to Mike Stratton and Paul Brenner, who really have been my partners
in crime, and with whom we are really excited to investigate whether this
specific early life mutagenesis is causing the early onset
colorectal cancer. But again, I want to emphasize, even if it isn't causing early
onset colorectal cancer, we are seeing a mutagenic exposure in
40% of young children, and this is something that's,
well, to put it mildly, not a good thing to be happening.
So one way or another, we need to figure out how we can stop this
early exposure, because we do not want a child at the age of two to have the
mutational burden of a 65-year-old.
With that, I want to just do brief acknowledgments.
The Mutographs team is very large with many people.
I'm just putting some of the key people.
In red are the first authors of the colorectal cancer study, Marcos Diaz-Gay, who
was a postdoc in my lab, and now he has his own lab in Madrid in the
CNIO. Sarah Moody at the Sanger, and then
Wellington at IARC.
I also want to make some special thanks to the Cancer Grand Challenges.
All of the work I showed here was funded by the Mutographs Cancer Grand
Challenge,
and all the work that we're doing in the future of understanding the mutational
signatures will be funded by, again, Cancer Grand
Challenges as part of Team Cause, by Cancer Research UK, NCI, and the Dutch
Cancer Society. And to be completely frank, one cannot wish for
better funders than Cancer Grand Challenges, because they really allow you to
dig deep into these global problems at scale.
And with that, thank you so much for your time and attention.
Well, thank you, Dr. Alexandrov, for that very thought-provoking
talk.
And so now it's my pleasure to introduce our last speaker, who is Dr.
Pepper Sheddian. She's a professor of
cancer biology at Oregon Health Sciences University, who will
discuss early onset breast cancer, lessons learned from
postpartum diagnoses.
So it's a real pleasure to be here. It's an honor to have been invited,
and the first three talks have been just phenomenal.
I'm going to be talking about young onset breast cancer from
the perspective of the interaction between a common
biology in young women, which is pregnancy, lactation, and weaning,
and how that might influence young onset breast cancer.
Young onset breast cancer is a two-body problem.
We have already heard that there's increased incidence in young onset breast
cancer, but it is also a disease of increased
mortality, which is most of what my talk is going to be focused
on today.
I have no disclosures. I did want to cover
reproductive
factors that have changed over the last 100 years as
potential mediators of the increase in young onset
breast cancer. And to do this work, I recruited
epidemiologist Zhenzhen Zheng from OHSU to help me with this
slide deck. And so here we're showing, using
the Connecticut Tumor Registry, which is one of the oldest registries in the
country, or is the oldest registry in the country, the increase
in young onset breast cancer over the decades.
And when you now look at average age of menarch, you can see that
this has decreased, and it's a known risk factor for breast
cancer in general, combined with the increased age at
first birth, with early age pregnancy being protective against
breast cancer. You see this widening gap
in recent years that was early on
identified by Malcolm Pike as the most important risk window
for future breast cancer risk. But what I want to highlight
here is if you look to the left of this red dotted
line, what you see is that the increase in early onset breast
cancer was already occurring for four decades
before these major changes in menarch and
age at first birth.
In a study by epidemiologist Mary
Beth Terry, she looked at the correlation between
parity across the same period of time and
concluded that there's no association between changes in
parity and increase in young onset breast cancer
specifically. And we have also looked at
breastfeeding,
and what you see here is the definition of breastfeeding being
never having breastfed or have had some
breastfeeding. And the good news is breastfeeding is clearly
increasing dramatically in the US, and this is wonderful
news for babies and mothers alike because of the metabolic benefits.
But again, you can see that there's not a strong correlation with the
increased incidence of young onset breast cancer.
These are all very important factors, and I don't want to minimize them, but I
think what we've seen in these first three presentations is the importance
of thinking more broadly about risk factors for breast cancer, for
generational changes that have been occurring, including
exposome,
forever chemicals, changes in diet, which has really dramatically
changed physical activity, and now after the last talk, we really need to
be thinking about
the bacterial exposure, and with the mammary gland being a
mucosal organ, I think that that is an important
lead.
So early on, working with
Virginia Borges, I'm going to focus on the research that's translational
because of this audience, we identified that women who
were
diagnosed within five years of a recent pregnancy
had significantly poorer prognosis than young women who were diagnosed and had
never been pregnant. And with further study, we found that this
increased risk of metastasis, poor survival,
persisted up through 10 years. And this was an
independent prognostic factor being diagnosed postpartum,
independent of ER status of the tumor, tumor size.
In a study done with Ken Smith and Zhen-Zhen Zhang, we also
could find, and this is a population-based study of the state of
Utah, a really powerful database where you can link
tumor incidence, survivorship data with
birth registries. So unusual
cohort. We could find that, again, women diagnosed within five
years of a recent childbirth had worse prognosis.
And I'm focusing here on the ER positive cases because of the beautiful
work
earlier from Dr. Sheng showing that it's ER positive cases that are
increasing. And in this Utah population database, we actually
found that the probability that a tumor would go on to
metastasize was the same if a woman had ER
positive or ER negative disease. Clearly, progression was
more rapid with ER-negative disease, and it was around 13% to
14% in this young women's cohort. But because three
times more women were diagnosed with ER positive breast cancer, three
times more women died of ER positive breast cancer,
highlighting the importance of a focus on ER positive breast cancer in
addition to ER negative breast cancer in young onset
cases. I was able to work with
Gareth Evans and Zhen-Zhen Zhang on a really important study where
we
had a population of germline BRCA 1 and 2
carriers. And so the question here was: would you still see this
promotional effect of a postpartum diagnosis, even in young onset breast
cancer cases that are being driven by dominant genetic mutations?
And I can say that Gareth Evans was genuinely surprised when we found that
a postpartum diagnosis conferred poor prognosis
compared to women who had never been pregnant in BRCA carriers, and
there was this very long tail of increased risk in PARUS
women. And so this is indicating a very dominant
biology that is driving this poor prognosis.
Early on,
I actually predicted based on rodent data that led
to these studies, that diagnosis during pregnancy would
not in fact confer poor prognosis.
And this was at odds with the current thinking about pregnancy associated breast
cancer, which had poor prognosis and was thought to be driven primarily by the
gestational hormones of
pregnancy, of which we can all agree makes sense.
And in a really important study by Frederic Amant, in
the very first large powered study that I'm aware of, they
could show clearly that a diagnosis during pregnancy, which mostly led
to treatment during pregnancy, did not confer poor prognosis.
And in a recent meta-analysis just published last month
from a group out of Greece with 21 studies that were
really looking at pregnancy associated breast cancer, meaning
cases diagnosed either during pregnancy or very
shortly after, the traditional definition of pregnancy associated
breast cancer, which I argue needs to be retired for
two distinct diseases. They also conclude that pregnancy itself does not
worsen breast cancer prognosis, that it's the postpartum
cases that conferred poor prognosis.
Further, postpartum breast cancer is not rare.
So in the
studies that I have been able to work with of almost
over 7,500 young onset cases where we have
known
childbirth data,
if you use the zero to five definition, between 25%
and 50% of all young breast cancer cases, or
25% to 45% of all young women diagnosed with breast cancer fall in this
high risk category. And if you extend the definition, which
shows up in some studies and not others, this long tail,
it's 50%. And so between 25% and 50% of all young
onset breast cancer cases fall into this high risk window for
metastasis.And globally, this has now
been recognized worldwide as an independent predictor
of poor survival, regardless of race,
ethnicity, culture, and access to
medical or type of medical care. So this is a dominant
biology. So what is this biology?
We call it the involution hypothesis, and I've been studying this for over 30
years, and it's the biology of where the mammary gland
remodels after lactation or remodels
after pregnancy, and this is called weaning-induced involution.
So if you don't nurse after pregnancy, it occurs at childbirth, or it
occurs upon weaning, including gradual weaning, which is the
common way that women wean. And in a simple
animal model study, you can put tumor cells, the same tumor cells, into these
distinct environments, and you can actually replicate the epi data
and show that involution is pro-tumor compared
to pregnancy. And what is driving this?
It turns out that postpartum involution uses classic wound-healing
programs to remodel the gland. That includes epithelial cell
death that triggers an immune-suppressive environment, fibroblast
activation to probably support the little chaos that
occurs as this gland undergoes this dramatic morphological change,
leading to tissue dysplasia and increased tissue tension.
There's an influx of immune regulatory cells, and there's a
loss of the myoepithelial cell barrier that would
prevent really early-stage disease from
shedding. And here in some images taken by Tracy
Lyons when she was a postdoc in the lab, you can see in GFP-labeled
tumor cells injected into the nulliparous mammary gland, these
well-behaved, not
metastatic shedding tumors. The same tumor cells
in the involuting environment rapidly disseminate,
shed, and access the vasculature to cause
micrometastases.
So what's the evidence that this could possibly be impacting human postpartum
breast cancer? Here is a study where
these are all early-onset cases. They're all ER positive.
They're all early stage and treatment naive.
And we did RNA seq analysis on them, and the only difference is
whether they were diagnosed in women who'd never been pregnant or were diagnosed in
the postpartum period. And you can see by
unsupervised hierarchical clustering that these cases
separate almost perfectly by reproductive state.
And evidence that involution may be involved in
this differential gene expression is strongly
suggested by the fact that if you look at these human breast tumors, you can
find in their gene expression signature, the
mammary gland involution signature that was originally defined in mouse models,
showing the immune suppression, the fibroblast
activation, and the
ECM deposition that is characteristic of normal
mammary gland involution. And string analysis starts to give
us hope for how we might be able to target these
particularly lethal cancers. We see that the
postpartum breast cancers
differ from nulliparous breast cancers in many ways, but I'm just going to point to
two
potential therapeutic targets, including they differ in their immune
profile, and they differ in cell cycle regulation, of which
there's
good treatments currently available that are not really
applied to these ER-positive cancers as much, especially early
stage.
And since we've published this work, three additional papers have looked at the
same question, and they confirm that
postpartum tumors are in fact distinct molecular
entities that have unique, aggressive
phenotypes in need of additional targeted therapies.
So I've
shown you that one mechanism of increased metastasis
is that these tumor cells more readily shed in the weaning
period. But we also find that there's a unique pattern of
metastasis.
There's three now independent studies that have looked at first site of metastasis
in young onset breast cancer cases separated by
nulliparous and postpartum cases.
And the postpartum cases are uniquely enriched in liver metastasis,
but not lung, brain, or bone.
We have modeled this in animals by injecting tumor cells
directly into the portal vein of either nulliparous
host livers or from mice who have recently undergone
weaning. And you can see in three different models in two different strains of
mice that we have increased tumor take in
this model, indicating that the liver
environment is distinctly different and fosters
establishment of metastasis in the postpartum period.
So what is this link between the mammary gland and the liver?
Well, this
biology has been a lot of fun to decipher.
So what we've learned is that as the mammary gland expands and
matures to be able to make milk and secrete it, the
liver also expands and increases metabolic output
and is the major source of the resources that are needed to
make milk. And so they're directly linked during lactation
to support the incredibly metabolic demanding process of
lactation. And surprisingly, we discovered,
mostly in rodent models, that upon weaning,
the liver also undergoes a weaning-induced liver
involution. And
most of this data is again published.
We have human correlative data that indicate that this is an
aspect of a normal, healthy pregnancy as well.
But I think the most compelling way to show this biology is with recent
RNA seq data that was published last
year by graduate student Michelle Ozaki, who has since gone on
to postdoc training.And what we find is that at the molecular
level, the liver mirrors the mammary gland with respect to
the transition between nulliparous and lactation and
the transition from lactation to weaning.
And so here you see individual animals from nulliparous
lactation, two, four, six, eight, and
eight days post-wean, and then regressed, which means that the mammary gland is
fully regressed and is no longer undergoing weaning-induced
involution. And if you look at cell cycle proliferation genes, you can
see in the liver, the normal liver, that's a hotspot for
proliferation during lactation, indicating the metabolic demand that the
liver is on and the need for additional hepatocytes to meet that demand.
You see, during lactation, this upregulation of anabolic
metabolism, including
materials that the mammary gland needs to make milk.
But as early as two days post-wean, there's a shift to catabolic
metabolism as these substrates build up, but there's no longer
suckling. There is a mechanism to reabsorb those into the
liver. This mechanism of resorption is actually directly
linked to the induction of hepatocyte cell death in
work that we've published. And this cell death is associated, again,
with fibroblast activation and this pretty intense
immune change in the
normal liver.
Michelle also looked for whether there was evidence for
involution-educated metastatic niche occurring, and she
used two publicly available data sets from
tumor-educated metastatic niches in the liver from PDAC and
gastric cancer and found that those
tumor-educated metastatic niches were both upregulated in our
normal liver. And so our model is that during weaning-induced
involution, the liver has a myriad of changes that
create a pre-metastatic niche in the absence
of a tumor.
But for the unfortunate group of young women who may have a tumor,
it makes a perfect site for metastasis and could
explain the increased risk of liver metastasis that's specifically
observed in postpartum patients.
Michelle went on in
work that's currently unpublished to try to understand what's the role of the
normal liver fibroblast in weaning to
establishing this metastatic niche, because it's known that cancer-associated
fibroblasts are very important in establishing the liver metastatic
niche in other
models. And so she developed a live infusion
protocol where we could enrich for the hepatic stellate cells, which are the liver
fibroblasts. And by a simple PCR analysis, you can see that this
enriched population expresses high levels of a canonical
fibroblast marker, PDGFRA alpha, but does not express
increased levels of CD45 immune marker, CD31
endothelial cell marker, or a marker for hepatocytes.
She then
isolated these liver fibroblasts from either
donor nulliparous mice livers or from mice that had
recently weaned, so involution day four livers,
combined those fibroblasts with tumor cells,
and then used a flank model and then asked, was there any difference in the ability
of these normal liver fibroblasts to differentially
impact tumor development? And you can see here that the tumors
grew more robustly in the involution group compared to the nulliparous
group, and this is data showing this increased tumor volume in
two different
models.
By performing single-cell RNAseq on this isolated population,
it was quite clear that the involution day four
fibroblasts are really molecularly quite distinct from the nulliparous and
distinct from the involution, which are shown here in blue.
And by using publicly available data sets,
Michelle was able to show that these nulliparous fibroblasts were
particularly enriched in previously published
cancer-associated fibroblasts
data sets from breast with fibroblasts that express high
levels of extracellular matrix proteins, from pancreatic cancer that express
high levels of extracellular matrix proteins in their activated state, and
from cancer-associated fibroblasts in breast that have immune
modulatory activity.
And consistent with these phenotypes, when she stained
these tumors for
matrix, here we're showing
collagen III, collagen I, and fibronectin.
You can see that the involution group tumors are more stromalized, and this
can be quantitated. And by multiplex IHC looking at the
immune milieu of these tumors, we can find that
the involution group tumors have an increase in tumor
cells that are known as myeloid-derived suppressor cells, and this is in
phenotype only.
And you can see this increase in the level of these cells in
involution tumors compared to nulliparous.
And then when you look at for the activated CD8
T cells that would be responsible for clearing these tumors, you can see a
suppression of that population. And this ratio is known to be very
important in regulating immune surveillance.
So with these studies,
we kind of felt like we had
shown clearly that postpartum breast cancer cases are at increased
risk for liver metastasis.
And we showed that weaning-induced involution is a very
likely mechanism to account for this increased risk.
And so we next wanted to ask, what could we learn by
looking at actual tumors, breast cancer liver metastasis
tumors in the metastatic site? And so this is work
done by Dr. Hatun Duran Cich in my group, who had a
poster a couple of days ago, and I hope some of you got to see it.
And the data-I'm going to show both of these data
combined because they're replicates.
Some people like graphs, some people like circles.
And what we found in our cohort-- So first of all, there's 47 women that were
enrolled in this study, and there was no selection criteria for these women.
We didn't look for young women. We didn't look for PARUS women, postpartum women.
We just took all comers with two criteria, that they would sign
informed consent and that they were not at any increased risk
by donating a research-only biopsy for our studies.
And what we found in this small cohort was that we
were already enriched in young women and postpartum breast cancer cases
compared to the national
average of young onset breast cancer and postpartum breast
cancer.
So one potential bias is that we could have an institution that sees an
exceptionally large number of young onset breast cancer patients, and that
is not the case. We find that the patient population at OHSU
reflects the national average. And so while this is a very small
study, it's pretty remarkable that already we're seeing this high enrichment in
young cases and high enrichment in postpartum cases.
Hatun went on to ask the question, what
were the primary cancers that these women were diagnosed with?
And this was pretty
eye-opening data for me. The vast majority of these women were
diagnosed with luminal A, the most indolent form of breast
cancer, and combined,
luminal cancers were the dominant by far.
50% of them were low grade, and 50% of them were low
stage. So these would be normally considered an indolent
cancer with low probability of metastasis, yet
here we have these cancers residing in the
liver. Hatun then went on to look
at what is the fate of these tumors in the liver themselves, and these dots
represent that these tumors retained their ER positivity at a high
level. And GATA-3 is a marker for luminal origin,
and you can see they're largely ER positive and luminal in origin.
The red dots represent ER positive cases that were positive
in the primary tumor but lost ER in the secondary site
in the liver, and you can see that they largely retained that luminal
phenotype. And these blue dots are the very few cases that we got
with taking all comers that were ER negative to begin with and
retained ER negativity in the
liver metastatic site.
So the question was,
how could these relatively indolent tumor cells that we think of
as having really low metastatic potential
be thriving so in the liver? And so we're only scratching the surface
on this, but I think it's a really important future direction.
To ask this question, we focused on cases where we had adjacent
normal
to the tumor. The normal is stained with HepPar, and
because these tumors are almost exclusively luminal, we stain the tumor for
GATA-3. And what we found was that the
vast majority of the way that these tumor cells
are interacting with the liver is through something called replacement growth,
which was originally defined in colon cancer metastasizing to the liver.
And the simplest way to describe it is the hepatocytes
are simply replaced with tumor cells.
So there's not a massive tumor that forms, but rather the tumor
seems to use the existing architecture of the liver to
establish itself, and this was a pretty dominant pathway.
And I think the most compelling way to show that we think that
many of these tumors really are
co-opting the existing liver with very little changes
to their own biology is shown in this image here, which on the left again
shows a HepPar positive
normal liver, the green tumor
cells. And here is stained for validated
liver sinusoidal markers.
I think you're hard pressed if we drew a line in here to say that
this is clearly tumor vasculature and this is clearly normal
vasculature. These tumor cells do not seem to need
the ability to induce new angiogenesis
desmoplasia. They seem to just readily
interact with the existing liver, which I think is going to be both a challenge and
hopefully a promise.
So in summary,
ER positive young onset breast cancer is increasing, and I think it's
important that we continue to study reproductive risk factors,
but I think it's probably more important at this point in
time to study lifetime exposures
and the massive changes in dietary
patterns and exercise and physical activity
that have occurred over the last 90 years.
I want to remind you that 75% of all young onset breast cancer
lethality actually occurs in ER positive cases,
with the highest mortality in postpartum breast cancer.
That doesn't say that we don't need to understand ER-negative disease because
it metastasizes much quicker.
The length of life is truly shortened in young onset breast cancer
cases with postpartum breast cancer with ER-negative disease.
That even patients with really classically really good prognostic
cancers, when diagnosed postpartum, are at risk
for liver metastasis. And this is really an opportunity for increased
surveillance, monitoring, and I would argue
increased treatment escalation.
That they're not indolent. They should be treated as high-risk
patients. And we believe that weaning-induced liver involution is the
likely mechanism. And so in sum, studying postpartum biology,
I think, represents a really unique opportunity for early
detection prevention, which I haven't really covered, which is a part of my
motivation, and treatment strategies.So clearly,
it takes a village to do this
work, and I want to highlight Hatun, Jackie,
and Michelle, current and recent past member of
the lab for the majority of the unpublished work that I cited.
And I want to highlight Grethe Albertsen,
who was the first epidemiologist who listened to
this C. elegans trained geneticist who said, "You know, I think
pregnancy-associated breast cancer might be two diseases." And they had the Million
Women Study in Norway, and she was
cautiously
collaborative.
And it has led to all of these wonderful
epidemiology studies, including collaboration with Dr Virginia
Borges, that has, I think, changed the face of young
onset breast cancer. And a final
call-out to the patient advocates and the numerous women who
volunteer tissues and time for our clinical
studies.
So, thank you very much.
Thank
you, Dr Shadeen. So I just have a few summaries,
slides to close out the session.
So a few take home messages, I think from today's talks, we've learned that cancer
incidence is rising in young adults across several different tumor types.
The trends are better visualized through a birth cohort lens rather than
age. Future disparities are already starting to emerge based on these
trends. And also trends in young adults are really potentially
early signals of broader trends in the population.
Colorectal cancer is an example of convergent pathways of
metabolic disease, microbiome, epigenetics across a life
course as cancer drivers in young adults.
Mutational profiling of tumors really point to early life factors
and exposures, and potentially things like cholabactin-producing
bacteria as a risk factor for early onset colorectal cancer.
And then early onset breast cancer has been hypothesized to maybe be associated
with changes in hormone exposure, although the epidemiological data is not quite
there, but is certainly associated with worsened outcomes, and
postpartum breast cancer may provide us some window into understanding that
disease.
So what are some future challenges and opportunities for the field of early onset
cancer? I think we need to do our best to leverage our knowledge
of existing risk factors. I think we have to do our best to identify new
risk factors through life course epidemiology cohorts,
novel approaches to biospecimen profiling to infer exposures
and also their biological effects, and develop methods to really
screen and prioritize candidate risk factors.
We need to really try to advance core association or causation through
mechanistic studies based on convergent animal and human models.
And then finally, invest in human trials to advance prevention.
So with that, I want to thank you for attending this morning's plenary,
and I wish you a good rest of the meeting. Thank you very much.